pessima come stai tutto bene punto per
le vacanze andate solo via per la
settimana di ferragosto andate in
campagna dei nonni in provincia
che bello vuoi invitare al cell monopoli
del compleanno di marco il 30 giugno web
sai che questo compleanno non verrà
nessuno e nome perché qui vado uffici
lasko andiamo tutti a santa si
praticamente sono 40 anni che ci
conosciamo tutti e tutti la casa libera
mi stanno insieme qualche quello che
quindi ci vendiamo sentono pensi
ovviamente abbiamo tutti le sul mare una
mia nel mio marito ex marito scusa
marcotullio ecco e lui sta che i bambini
io so con i cani nel lato è se lo avessi
finire in mezzo fa è sicuramente vacanze
più esotiche come una volta e non si
direbbe ma è un po hippy che qualche
nell 82 compatto questa villa e bari e 5
luglio in tutta la nascosa dei nostri
amici olandesi per 3 milioni e mezzo di
euro indovina dove gli investiti no cara
il mattone non vale più nulla da essa ha
vestito tutto in kit line effetti poi
non voglio di ghiacci con questi
discorsi che diceva sono capi ora guarda
scappa perché mi stanno aiutando il
circolo sia una qualità di partner ciao
tesoro e buone vacanze con compleanno
tattiche le cose